الله الينا الزميلت مزار مراسل صباح
العربيه في فرنسا ومن اجمل ملايات ليحكيني
على الولاده اهلا بك يا ريت يسعد صباح
الخير لكم جميع النوال
[موسيقى]
اذا حكينا عن السويد بقوموا بحرق ماعز
كبير وهو اول يوم احد في عيد الميلاد مما
يطفي القليل من البهجه على الاجواء
الشتويه بالسويد بتعرفوا كيف بتكون
الاجواء عندهم اذا حكينا عن اليابان شرق
العالم ياكلون تنتف رايت سكن كي اف سي
انه بدات الفكره في 70 مش السوسه في
سبعيات القرن الماضي عندما بدا السياح
الاجانب الذين يزورون اليابان في تناول
هذا الدجاج المقلي بدل من الديك الرومي
وهذا طبعا ذكر الروم التقليدي طبعا في
اعياد الميلاد وسرعان انتشر الامر بين
السكان المحليين اليابانيين مبيعات الدجاج
المقلي في اليابان اعلى بخمس مرات خلال
فتره الاعياد من المواسم العاديه هذا
بنحكي شويه اقتصاد
التركي
اما هناك في القاره الامريكيه اذا رحنا
على بوقته كولومبيا تخيلوا انه انا مش مش
راح اجربها ولا ولا بعرفها ولا بدي اعرفها
على فكره هوت شوكلت الشوكولاته ساخنه
بحطوا فيها قطع جبنه وبدنابلوها بس في
فتره الاعياد الطعم راح يكون غريبه
بتقول انه لا الحامض والحلق المالح والحلو
يجتمعان معا لانه عندكم بالمغرب العربي
خصوصا بالجزائر كثير اكلات فيها مالحه و
حلوه
اذا رجعنا على كولومبيا بصنعوه هذه المواد
بتكون الحلوه المالحه اذا صحت تعبير في
اعياد الميلاد خاصه فهذه العا- العاده
الكولومبيه المفضله تصنع باذابه قطعه من
الجبن في الشوكولاته ساخنه حتى تذوب ويتم
شربها وغالبا ما تؤكل قطعه الجبن بالملعقه
خير بالمعلقه هلا اذا رجعنا كمان مره على
دول شمال اوروبا اقصى شمال اوروبا عند
القطب الجنوب القطب الشمالي يخفي
النرويجيون مكانسهم مكان المكانس بعيدا عن
الاعين خايفين انهم يعني عندهم يؤمنوا بان
همم ببساطه باسطوره باسطوره قديمه تقول
انه اذا تركت
طوال الليل فان السحر السيئين سوف
يسرقونها ثم يركبونها ويحدثون الفوضى طوال
الموسم عيد الميلاد
عندهم كل مجتمع عند التقاليد مختلفه وعند
عق- هيك افكار بتكون غريبه يعني انا
امبارح كمان
ولفتوا لي نظري على شغله انه عم بستنى
سانتا كلوز عشان يجي بالليل يحط الهدايا
فخلوني احط له همم مج حليب وصحن كوكيز
يعني هاي كانت جديده جديده همم
همم
تلقى الايطاليون مطالبات بترشيد استخدام
الطاقه وخفض الفواتير بينما طلبت فنلندا
من مواطنها قضاء وقت اقل في حمامات السونا
عشان يوفروا الكهرباء كما عطاء همم اطفئت
او اطفات المخابز انوارها احتجاجا منها
على ارتفاع الفواتير هولندا قررت ان تريل
الاضواء نصف الوقت العادي للتوفير وبلديه
امستردام الهولنديه قررت استخدام مصابيح
اللد لتوفير الاستهلاك وفي فرنسا بنرجع
شوي الى فرنسا وفي بلده فيغو
وهي بلده يسكنها 5000 نسمه استغنى رئيس
البلديه عن الاضواء بفضل مجموعه من
المتطوعين قاموا ببناء زينه عيد الميلاد
من الخشب الذي يمكن اعاده تدويره وطبعا
وباريس اصبحت احدث مدينه اوروبيه تعلن عن
اتخاذ اجراءات التوفير الطاقه وخطط همم
وخطط لاطفاء الانوار
انت برج بيستاب ثالث شهير كما ستنتهي
الاحتفالات والزينه في الثاني من يناير
بدلا من التاسع
اناره الشانزليزيه والتورفال لحد 2 يناير
بدل 9 من يناير
الله يخليكم
بالابتسامه مهمه جدا للابتسامه لانها تؤدي
مرات واغلب الاوقات للسعاده الى العمل